all right so as we pick up with Power
Man and Iron Fist part two which I know
in the last video I said Iron Man and
power fist somebody pointed that out in
the comments and I thought it was pretty
funny um one thing I want to remind you
guys is this story's not meant to be
taken seriously this is not meant to be
a you know civil war two kind of story
you know Power Man and Iron Fist were a
great duo but the history of their team
ups were usually comedic they were never
designed to be serious stories they were
designed to simply just be goofy and
funny and for people to have a good time
so don't take Power Man and Iron Fist
too seriously guys you will you'll not
you won't enjoy yourselves if you do so
the last video we had talked about how
you know their former secretary for
Heroes for Hire Ginny had been thrown in
prison after murdering her boyfriend who
was abusive and the result was that
during her time in prison she had met a
girl named necro and necro had basically
informed you know Ginny of an artifact
called the supersoul stone and that
those individuals who put markings on
their bodies and utter a incantation
will be endowed with absolute power it
was considered to be nonsense and the
result is that once Ginny got out of
jail and she immediately began speaking
with a woman named Mariah Diller now
again mariah Dillard was a villain whose
greatest criminal scheme and I think
it's probably one of the most
intelligent criminal schemes were ever
heard of her greatest criminal scheme
was using an ambulance to pick up dead
bodies robbing them other valuables and
then disposing of the bodies I know it's
a terrible thing to say but again it's
not the most unintelligent criminal
scheme and I've ever heard of but the
result here is that you know with with
things being as they are Luke Cage and
iron fists did not know that this was
the case they had total faith in Jenny
because Jenny had worked for them for so
long they had no reason to believe that
she was going to be a villain but as
things progressed and they learned that
the necklace belonged or was in
possession of a guy named tombstone
again a street-level villain that when
they know when the necklace had
effectively been taken that tombstone
had basically blamed them for the entire
situation he said that it was an easily
preventable thing of course they were
the ones that took it where they didn't
take it realizing what was going on they
took it believing that it was truly
Ginny's necklace that had belonged to
her grandmother and so again because of
the fact that
at you know tombstone had been pursuing
the necklace so intently Luke Cage and
Iron Fist had basically come to the
conclusion that maybe there was more to
the story than they were being told and
so their goal was to track down Ginny
and find out what was going on and so we
picked out with Luke Cage and and again
Jessica Jones and as the two of them
were talking with one another you know
Iron Fist is right around the corner and
listening to everything that's going on
and he's basically being badmouth like
you wouldn't believe
Jessica Jones seems to hate him but as
we know with Jessica Jones character and
as Luke Cage points out to Danny Rand
later in the story Jessica Jones means
of displaying affection is by being
really mean to people and I know it
seems weird but if she didn't care about
it's one of those classic examples if
she didn't like him she wouldn't give
him a hard time and that's basically
what happens once Luke Cage and Danny
Rand are asked to explain everything
that's going on the story is as crazy as
the sounds now again what they tell
Jessica Jones is basically what I just
told you guys a second ago and Jessica
it's kind of like okay fine go do what
you guys need to do but just so you know
this sounds incredibly dumb and so what
we do is we pick up with Jenny and we
pick up with with Mariah Dillard and as
they have this power of the supersoul
stone because of the fact that it allows
its user ELISA seems to endow its user
with super-strength and they immediately
take to a 24-hour grocery store which is
actually a front for illegal gambling
and when they get in there they
basically robbed the joint they knock it
over
they take everybody's jewels they take
everybody's money they take everything
valuable that they have now switching
back to Luke Cage and iron fists again
they're on the hunt but they're also
being followed by two henchmen of
Tombstone and the question that's being
asked is why you know why are these guys
following Danny Rand and I'm sorry Danny
Rand and Luke Cage you know why is this
thing so important and the reason why is
because what black Mariah and what Ginni
have been doing is actually knocking
over tombstones establishments their
goal is to basically take over his
gambling or I take it I guess take over
his criminal empire and asked him
entirely probably kill him in the
process and so while he's screaming at
his henchmen in a voice that's barely
audible says that's kind of the
cornerstone of his character Luke Cage
and iron fist travel to dr. Strange's
mystic Arcanum now
this is one of my favorite points in the
story not because of dr. strange but
because the guy that we meet afterwards
of course with them delving into the
realm of something that has to do with
mysticism dr. strange is kind of the
go-to guy and again in the last video I
had mentioned that you know that the
David Walker was not making any
references to Luke ages time as head of
the Mighty Avengers that was actually
something I was wrong about apparently
he was he did mention that in a single
line had somebody us didn't catch it but
somebody in the comics pointed it out
which is fine um but when they went to
go meet dr. strange the question they
had is do you know anything about the
supersoul stone and dr. strange his
response is nope as far as he knows
there's nothing like that but he also
takes potshots which is kind of its kind
of both common and uncommon if those of
you guys who don't know in Marvel Comics
Doctor Strange was a very arrogant you
know a surgeon and he learned to be
humble on his way to becoming the
sorcerer supreme but he still maintained
a bit of arrogance and what he basically
says is that there are inferior forms of
magic basically parlor tricks and street
magic and those things aren't to be
taken seriously that he is dr. strange
is the master of the mystic arts and if
it's magic worth knowing about then he
knows about it basically saying if the
supersoul stone is a magical artifact
it's totally irrelevant in the realm of
mystic arts and so Danny ran kind of
points us how he takes notice of this
and so Luke eight says now they're going
to go to go to a geyser they should have
gone to in the first place they're going
to go to a guy named senior magic ho now
I really hope you guys put his name down
in the comment section because I just
want to see people just the head type
senior magic Oh in the comment section
of this video this guy is amazing this
is this is one of the funniest moments
uh senior magic ho is I guess imagine
you know he's a he's a master of
street-level mystic arts and he knows
about the supersoul stone now when he's
told that dr. strange didn't know what
the supersoul stone was the senior magic
Oh says he's from two on high he doesn't
understand the intricacies of magic more
so than that
senior magic Oh says he's forgotten more
than doctors trained we'll know which is
the silly but again this points to the
spilling nature of Neil cour Man and
Iron Fist comics but what he tells us is
that there is or there was an entity
named Anansi and a non-si was basically
a guy he was a street-level or not
released
a magician but he was a guy who used
street level magic in order to play
tricks on people so think of him as like
the street level magic version of Loki
from Asgard but the supersoul stone was
created and would endow its wielder with
limitless power if that individual was
able to put those runes on their skin
and then utter the enchantment the same
way that that Ginny did the problem with
this is that from the point of this
ceremony is performed up until you know
this limitless power is officially
bestowed the supersoul stone will start
to influence the personality of that
person and because the supersoul stone
was designed to explicitly only be used
by weak people it's effectively taking
over the mind of Ginny as a weak human
being and turning her into an absolute
monster both physically and emotionally
and so Luke Cage and iron fists come to
the conclusion that they were basically
duped that there is a lot there in there
in a lot of trouble that things are
really going to become absolutely
chaotic but what see newah magical also
says is that the only way to defeat the
supersoul stone is to basically combat
its wielder with strength greater than
the strength that the supersoul stone
gives the problem with this is that
senior magico has no idea what that
means and neither does anybody else and
so they're just kind of left to their
own devices to do what they can and so
from here we switch to Jenny now this is
not a super important moment this is
simply just David Walker showing us how
this how the supersoul stone corrupts
its wielder in the sense that Jenny's
becoming more tyrannical Jenny's
becoming more insane black mariah's
attempts to to keep her from going crazy
and you know trying to a suede Jenny by
telling her to control her rage don't
let the great control her which is some
advice they got from their prison
psychiatrist it's simply uneffective
that jenny is just going forward as a
wildly powerful being who is basically
going insane and drunk with power and so
on their way to try to both find Jenny
and figure out what's going on with this
super soulstone Danny Rand and Luke Cage
run into the henchmen that are following
them at the orders of Lonnie Lincoln the
issue here is that once they arrive at
the safe house of Lonnie Lincoln he's
immediately thrown out of it and when he
comes to he tells both iron fists and
Luke Cage that because they're Heroes
for Hire he's hiring them and the reason
why is because he needs to be protected
from Jenny who has since transformed
into a monstrous beast with the
intention of killing Tombstone and so
from here we pick up with the final
issue of Power Man and Iron Fist and man
I got to tell you guys this comic this
comic went off the rails fast so of
course with Ginny kind of laying waste
you know attacking everybody is what you
see in these kind of stories where she's
just tearing things apart she's ranting
and raving about you know making
everybody beg for mercy and then killing
them but the other half of this is that
more idler didn't expect things to go
this way in her mind the supersoul stone
would probably grant super strength or
maybe some kind of energy based powers
and it would allow her and Ginny to just
rise up and take over tombstones Empire
making themselves extremely rich
something equivalent or maybe a little
bit less than the kingpin but the exact
opposite happened Ginny absolutely lost
her mind turned into a monster and is
just killing people and so Luke Cage and
Danny ran try to recall what it was but
senior magico said that be strength the
only way to defeat those with the
supersoul stone is to use strength
greater than the strength of the super
super soul stone Luke Cage comes to the
realization and that this strength is
the power of love this is weird and so
he's going theory of course he has a
vehicle thrown at him he dodges the
vehicle he shouts sweet Christmas
because it's a Luke Cage it has located
in the story and the idea here is the
only way for Luke Cage to reach Ginny is
to reach her on a personal level to get
past all the insanity that's going on
and talk to her as best he can to be
honest with you guys I'm reaching the
Trident rig as a reasonable explanation
on this but but because everything
that's happening no one quite really
knows how to handle the situation mariah
is reaching out to Jan
because of the fact that the two of them
have been so closer relatively close and
in the end she'll actually be the one to
save the day here but immediately going
after tombstone the idea of Danny Rand
is to get tombstone out of here as fast
as you can
but he and then in the end they don't
and what is up happening is Luke Cage
and Danny ran used their own version of
the fastball special now for those of
you guys who don't know about the
fastball special this is a hallmark of
Colossus and Wolverine and it's
literally just Colossus picking
Wolverine up and throwing him at a
target and this is what Luke Cage does
because Danny rands Iron Fist gives him
a fist literally allows him to channel
his Chi into his fists and make it iron
hard he simply does this and then gets
thrown at at Jennie the problem with
this is Ginny just kind of dodges out of
the way
and so iron fist crashes into a pole
from here we switch to black Mariah
named black Mariah of course you know is
this is one of the funny things she's
not really taking Danny ranch seriously
and no one ever really does uh in truth
the Oh Danny ran of course being a
street level character you know being so
exceptional in his fighting abilities
this this story's not designed to show
him serious and so the result is that
he's called names like the kung-fu kid
or he's called names like kungfu grip uh
he's just not taken very seriously but
the scene or the situation ends up
turning directly to black by herself and
what she says is yes
Jenny's been wronged she's been cheated
she's been screwed over she's been the
subject of an abusive boyfriend she was
forced to endure life in prison but both
black Mariah and Jenny made their time
in prison as best they could they did
what they could do you know Jenny taught
black Mariah how to read she shared
great moments with the Heroes for Hire
Luke Cage and iron fists but despite all
this jenny does not necessarily seem to
be paying attention but what we learned
is that this entire situation is really
just Jenny lashing out it's really just
like a physical manifestation of all the
anger and all the rage that she's ever
felt and simply saying that she doesn't
wanna be hurt anymore just want to be
victimized anymore so it seems as though
David Walker is kind of going for this
undercurrent of you know Jenny tried to
stand up for herself the best way she
knows how
and the best way that she knew how to do
that was to draw incantations on her
scan utter an inch hamon that she didn't
understand anything about and then turn
into a giant monster and so once this
happens once she sort of lets all his
anger go she's a stronger person because
of it
then because of super-soul Stone cannot
influence those who are strong-willed
people its power dissipates in its
entirety and Gina reverts back to her
normal human form and so from here
Tombstone basically says that he wants
the the super-soul stone necklace back
but Danny Rand and Lou cage say no
that's not gonna happen they're not
going to leave that in the hands of
someone like Tombstone no way because if
anybody else were to get their hands on
it they could run into the same
situation again and so Judi and black
Mariah sort of mend their friendship and
the necklace is taken back to senior
magic ho
what an amazing Carriger it's I'm gonna
read that I want to read a story about
senior magic Oh they take the necklace
back to senior magic ho and senior magic
Oh ask the question does this mean that
Luke Cage and iron fist are back
together again and Luke Cage says yes
and so this is effectively the story
telling us how Power Man and Iron Fist
came back together as the Heroes for
Hire would that be said uh yes this
series would have made a much better
episode of the rundown oh this would
have made I didn't think about that when
I first started it but I was reading
through it I was like this would have
been a much better episode of the
rundown but it wasn't bad now you know
when you read it for what it is when you
read it for series that's not supposed
to be taken seriously you have one hell
of a time but if you do take it
seriously you know you're probably not
gonna enjoy yourself too much so ah this
would make a great comic story in video
here's what this would make anyway guys
I'm gonna bounce off here and you know
drop a like if you guys enjoyed this
video hit the sub button leave a comment
let me know what you guys think and I
won't catch you all in it peace